hi I'm David I'm Ryan and today zack
snyder tweeted the first image of Ben
Affleck is Batman for a Batman vs
Superman which is a tentative title so
there you saw it and here we are to talk
about it yes all right what are your
what are your thoughts you looking
forward to it
yeah it's different than any Batman suit
we've seen in a movie it's got the small
ears which is more of a classic look it
also has a cloth look looks like it's
covered in cloth although it looks like
he's still wearing armor the look of Ben
Affleck in the suit is good he looks
like a little bit of an older Batman as
we all anticipated Ben Affleck's chin
looks very good in this yeah that's
definitely Ben Affleck like how you can
tell from like the chin kind of like the
Frank Miller John both like yeah like
the Dark Knight Returns definitely has a
football player vibe yes now if it goes
far like he doesn't look obese Oh
certainly
bulky which is which is right from he's
a he's a bruiser you know yeah okay so
looking back at the like the 1989 Tim
Burton Batman costume it was very black
very sleek and it had that gold logo on
the chest they kind of really stood out
like a spotlight and then we kind of
moved into the Joel Schumacher nipples
and we also had the mr. freeze like ice
Batman costume just clearly with nipples
clearly meant to sell more toys it's
like look how many different Batman
costumes yeah ed it very like now Batman
with like ice fighting action yeah and
then we got into the Batman V games
which is kind of actually a little bit
similar to this one we're sort of big
and bulky but still very robber looking
and then we got into the more motorcycle
Batman with the Dark Knight so I think
this really fits into an interesting
sort of timeline of different Batman
costumes I'm really excited about the
look of it I like the look of the
Batmobile which is behind him it's like
a hybrid between the classic look and
the tumbler yes yesterday zack snyder
also tweeted a picture of the Batmobile
at least just the back wheels with a
sort of a tarp over it now we're kind of
seeing the front and we kind of get a
good shape and size of how how big it is
I think it looks a lot like the timber
and maybe even like the 1994 cartoon
Batman for like massive
phantasm I also think that the logo on
the chest now this is a black-and-white
photo so we don't know probably know
that logo is blue yellow I'm reading I
believe I think it'll just be the plain
old like black and gray but I actually
think it might Moodle I think it could
be blue only because Gimli always kind
of draws with a very blue tint and I
think the logo looks definitely like the
Frank Miller it's very square it's like
it's much bigger than the others Nolan 1
we also know that that Batman and
Superman fight in the Dark Knight
Returns and when they revealed that
they're making this movie in Comicon
they they used a monologue for that so
it wouldn't be far-fetched to think that
they're pulling on Frank Miller's Batman
quite a bit so I'll let us know what you
think of this Batman costume in the
comments yeah we really do want to know
what everybody thinks because we're kind
of fans of it but you know this is a
very heated debate for people so we want
to know what you yeah let us know what
you think with a Batmobile do you agree
with Zack Snyder's decision to sort of
go the Frank Miller route what's your
favorite Batman costume and such yeah
all those things and more below until
next time I'm Ryan I'm David thank you
for watching